on est au coeur d'une audace et la
filière laitière qui s'expose et si vous
voulez vraiment voir la franche comté
il faut absolument venir ici parce que
les nuls de mamirolle et poligny font
des démonstrations et c'est vraiment le
sens qu'on a décidé c'est de valoriser
l'ensemble des produits issus dinet
c'est du lait qu'il ya du salon assez
les pages du salon on récupère à peu
près 60 litres de lait par jour et on va
le transformer sur cinq postes
différents
la tombe à l'eau réchauffée on va les
crimes et et on va récupérer le lait
écrémé pour en faire deux types de
fromage frais différents
les fromages lactique
plus tôt au lycée et puis un fromage
leur lycée et puis l'autre qui est
plutôt de la faisselle où on va bouger
simplement ce qu'on attendait mais celle
ensuite on va faire avec la crème à
faire le beurre de baratte
donc c'est le troisième produit
l'honneur ça fait un autre co produit
qui en fait le trader elle se bat
d'heure on en fait un un autre produit
on a lancé c'est l'élection du bureau
on peut déguster aussi sur le salon en
fait rien ne se perd rien ne se perd on
essaye de valoriser au mieux tous les
produits de la fabrication
l'autre lieu incontournable c'est le
hall 3 la wii à la bourgogne franche
comté
ici c'est une ambiance très festive
s'avère plus de la soir c'est la fête
on est là pour déguster les produits
régionaux discuter beaucoup de francs
comtois aussi et c'est ce que vous allez
voir avec quelque chose de totalement
nouveau sur le salon
[Applaudissements]
la première fois que vous venez en salon
qu'est ce qui vous a motivée en fait de
si nous a motivés c'est de faire
découvrir nos produits un grand nom un
grand public
et puis de voir les retours ceux tout
aussi des clients le premier c'est
vraiment comme je disais de promouvoir
la filière brassicole franc comtoise et
puis enfin découvrir ce produit qui a
pas eu que le vin et quel fromage en
franche comté
aujourd'hui dans la bras s'ils comptent
trois oncles associations qui vont
peuvent 22 brasseur franc comtois on a
créé une coopération que nous que ce
soit pour une filière d'hors-jeu franc
comtois de l'approvisionnement certaines
matières premières
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]